hey how you doing
foreign
[Music]
I got all this stuff I never put it in
um
thank you
it doesn't matter
okay
so we should be out of here in what like
four minutes John says 130. what John
yeah no way
yeah
Department
call Justin
um
large
yeah this is
all right uh chair rules we have a
quorum
and uh
we will go through these bills uh as
best we can here
starting out with house bill 39.
and house bill 39. you are you do you
okay House Bill 39 representative Cole
second by representative hunt moves in
expedient to legislate
and representative Cole is recognized to
speak to his notion
thank you Mr chair
uh the committee voted unanimously eight
so yeah yeah we we usually have another
sentence that that uh uh because you're
going to have to write a blurb you have
to write excuse me report
excuse me we have to write a committee
report so you want to practice what
you're going to say in the committee
report as to why the committee uh the
subcommittee decided that was an exceed
so uh um obviously writing blurbs is
going to be a whole new art form for you
new members to learn and uh I will
certainly help you out the rule general
rule of thumb when you write a blurb is
you write what the bills list intended
to do
and then you write if there was an
amendment what the amendment does if
there's no Amendment then you would say
after you wrote what the bill was
intended to do you would then say uh
however the committee felt that the
problem with a bill would XYZ now when
you write your blurb the one of the
tricks that I have is if you take the
the bill does someone have the bill in
okay so if you take the bill in front of
you
and then when you see that it says
analysis
cut and paste that
okay that's what the bill does this bill
makes changes you know and blah blah
this is UCC that's not that bill
okay so the bill oh this is even better
it's like two sentences okay the bill
prohibits a person from doing business
in the state from charging an additional
fee for receiving a paper billing
statement elected to make a payment by
the United States mail or attempting to
pay a bill in person the committee felt
this was unworkable unenforceable
and and not really appropriate in just
say problematic
or or you can research what I wrote last
question or you can research what I
wrote last year and steal it just yeah
right because it was the same bill
that's another another trick okay
okay so I I uh yeah okay or I can send
it to you the motion uh is being to
legislate the clerk will call the roll
right
this is the wrong committee hang on
hang on from here it is that was from
the Clark the house court that was my
right now I
know she's good yeah good representative
Ammon I vote Yes
Osborne yes
petusic yes Terry yes post yes
Cole yes
but Shelly
Jackson yes Walsh yes
Burrows yes Herbert
Clark yes
the clear yes
spear
oh I answered for someone else before
I'm so sorry I didn't hear you vote
again you mentioned my name but you
didn't pronounce it correctly so I
Sullivan yes
and chairman hunt yes all right okay the
vote is uh 19 to zip
um all those in favor of placing the
house bill 39 in the consent Calendar
please say aye aye those opposed say no
so moved unanimously
okay House Bill 42 relative to the uh is
there okay so is there a Minority Report
um
okay all right this is this is good when
all right relative to the operation of
certain homeowners associations House
Bill 42 we have an amendment to house
bill 42.
and
okay
all right so the subcommittee knew that
we had these two amendments and um did
not know that uh we could get it done so
quickly
um so who would like to make them I'll
just make the motion is that well
somebody else wants to do it
anybody
okay you can be you can teach us okay
all right so um I I move uh uh ought to
and I don't bother with the H because
that means the house and it's only
amendment we we wouldn't be voting on
so because there's an amendment number
you write the amendment there so the
no this committee
why do you want why do you want to vote
against it no I am what my motion is
ought to pass
okay
and uh second RIP by representative
petusic
okay so what this amendment does it
brings in the two concerns that people
had
um in particular in these it's Roman
numeral two it's actually in one and two
that it has to be
um the the homeowners association had to
have been created by the planning board
actually it's not in one it's just in
two no Homer Association constant of
this chapter and approved by the
planning board so that's the one
Amendment the second amendment was uh to
take out time shares not that I could
imagine that any timeshare has a
homeowners association but
anything can happen
so those are the two amendments
okay
so the motion is ought to pass on the
right Ammon yes
Osborne
yes
Pacific
Terry
yes
host yes
Cole yes for jelly
Paxton
yes Walsh yes
Burrows yes
Herbert yes
clerk yes McAleer yes
Vincent Yes
collabro yes
fire spear your spear yes just don't
look at that yeah I know very
disconcerting Sullivan yes
now representative hunt seconded by
representative petusic moves ought to
any discussion on the motion about to
pass on Amendment seeing none the clerk
Ammon yes
Osborne yes
but Tuesday yes Terry
yes post yes Cole yes
for jelly yes Thaxton yes Walsh yes
Burrows yes Herbert yeah
oh yeah yes
McAleer yes Vincent Yes
Gibbs yes
sphere yes Sullivan
yes
I believe you needed a motion in a
second
yeah the motion was my man by me that
was on the amendment the same uh same
people is that automatic or did you say
no I did say it okay well I was thinking
a tip
okay
uh uh so the Motions the past in 19 zip
all those in favor placing on the
consent Calendar please say aye
oh
you're completed again
okay
uh relative to repair of Home Appliances
uh
okay the recommendation is to retain it
because remember said I feel it wanted
us to retain it and he's not here okay
so we just wait till he gets here
because he's the one who wanted to
retain yeah
okay
that's all right well all right so the
next one is uh house bill
173. I don't even remember talking did
we talk about this oh that's right
um
okay so 173 we need to we need an
amendment to repeal the whole building
code
but we wanted to retain it yes oh that's
right because we have to wait till after
they have done Implement right the
building code is implemented okay all
right so who would like to make the
motion to retain
representative Ammon
segment representative patusek
moves to retain yep
173.
okay
all right
um
you want to speak to your motion I can
speak briefly uh so we heard testimony
that the state building codes are going
to be updated at some future point which
will make the entire RSA Obsolete and so
changing the RSA uh would be meaningless
at that point so the idea is to hold on
to the bill and hopefully those codes
will be updated by next session
uh next year and we can uh amend the
bill to make it more appropriate
okay
any discussion on the motion to retain
seeing none uh I guess I have to roll
call this you know
in the old days it used to be the chair
just has the sense I loved it that I
could just unilaterally call it retained
so
oh you have to call
you I thought you said you had to do
this no no no no no we so Mr chairman on
a retain you don't have the opportunity
to say without objection so ordered I
wish I did I used to then I used to by
rule you can't do that anymore not
anymore now we have to roll call
everything we have to have a roll call
and this is not Washington
all right then
um this is on retaining HB 173 correct
Ammon yes Osborne
too sick Terry
yes
post yes Cole yes richelli yes Paxton
yes Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert
clerk yes McAleer yes Vincent yes
Gibbs yes
spear yes Sullivan yes and chairman hunt
yes
all right motion carries the vote in
19-0 all right moving on next is uh
Hospital 178 relative enforcement of
condominium leans for assessment
I believe we want to retain this
yeah
okay who would like to make the retain
motion
no there's no blurb there's no blurb for
retaining
okay okay representative Herbert you're
recognized to speak to your retaining
motion
hello
now
um
my my thing was uh the the uh the
problem with uh tying the lean to
um a mortgage and and the uh you might
end up
putting in 2500 lien and
on a five hundred thousand dollar condo
which doesn't make any sense
perfect okay so the motion is to retain
uh
the clerk will call
the role
Ammon yes
Osborne yes
fatusic yes Terry
yes
post yes
cool yes
for jelly yes Paxton yes Walsh yes
arrows yes Herbert no not yet
clerk yes
McAleer yes
Vincent yes collabro yes
Gibbs yes
spear yes Sullivan
German hunt yes
okay motion passes in 19 to zip
all right next up the house bill 239 no
that's what we just did yeah
no no no that's a condominating
disclosure financial information
I don't think we're ready for this one
right
foreign
Amendment
John yeah that's what I thought take up
later so this is not an early bill so
I'm not worried about it so we will not
okay next up House Bill 459 relative
transaction exempt from the regulation
of businesses practices for the consumer
okay
bottom of the pile okay
all right representative uh Ammon and uh
representative Phil is not here so uh
seconded by representative patusek moves
speak to the motion
and representative Ammon is recognized
to speak to his motion
uh we heard testimony that the reason
that exemptions exist for certain
categories of Industry
is because
those Industries are highly regulated
and uh having an exemption for uh
personal right to action would have
unintended consequences with existing
regulation and uh even though the bills
is well intentioned it would cause uh
uh some a little bit of chaos with
existing regulations so therefore move
Ito
okay
oh let him get in a seat so he can
participate okay
okay so the motion with is index being
to legislate on House Bill 459.
okay
all right so the clerk will call the
role on index being to legislate
hb459 correct um Ammon yes Osborne yes
batusic yeah
Terry yes
post yes Cole yes
pacelli yes Paxton
Walsh yes sparrows yes Herbert yeah
Clark yes McAleer yes
Vincent Yes
collabro yes
Delio
yes
spear yes
Sullivan
and chairman hunt yes
okay
19-1 I was no she voted no oh she voted
no
19-1 okay
okay uh minority
uh are you okay representative Gibbs are
you all right to put this on the consent
calendar or you want it on the regular
account okay and would you like to write
a blurb
excuse me a Minority Report
I guess I will have to no you don't have
to but
but you probably should
um will somebody let me know when I will
need to do this you theoretically uh we
we tell you to do it by the end of the
day I I always give people one day so we
assume that you go home tonight and and
do it tonight and email it to me
tomorrow
okay
that would be great
and your motion would be ought to pass
uh we'll do House Bill 73 relative to
repair of Home Appliances because you
wanted to make the retained motion
right okay so uh representative uh
second in by representative patusek
moves uh to retain
and you're recognized to speak to your
motion
uh because the wallet is a
Sound Idea it still needs some work in
terms of making more in line with what
we've seen in other states as well as
other jurisdictions
um
we need to recognize consumers rights to
maintain
control over their own appliances but as
it is worded at this time it's
unenforceable
perfect
Ed
he's my default
actually John said yep
all right and it's an un retaining uh
hb70
HP 73 correct
Ammon yes
yes Terry yes
post yes
Cole yes
you can't have to vote yeah you have to
just so you know if you're not going to
vote on something if you don't want to
feel comfortable you need to get up and
walk out of the room before the question
is you can't abstain under Masons no
matter walk out of the room just get out
of the room quickly do not wait until it
run to the nearest bathroom
you always got to have someone do that
in the first session
Walsh yes
Burrows yes Herbert
clerk yes macklier yes Vincent yes
collabro yes
philio
yes
Gibbs yes
spear
yes reluctantly
all right
Sullivan
okay so yeah we have Osborne
1901. okay
moving right along
okay
if we'll we'll take it up if it's if if
we're not done prior to that so sorry
what happened to 465
459 is it makes me into legislate 19 to
1 and you're running The Minority Report
sorry
you can always change your vote by the
way
you're right I was looking at the wrong
list
all right uh all right so we'll hold off
on 279. next is uh House Bill 146
who made the motion
I think I did
all right representative below uh second
and representative below is recognized
to speak to her motion well
um I believe the Liquor Commission
should be responsible for
um opening closing stores they have all
the information uh we don't as
legislators I think
um it gets um we don't want to interfere
uh if we do it's micromanaging so I
believe the Liquor Commission should be
responsible for
um
opening and closing liquor stores
any more discussion on the motion of
inexpeding to legislate
Osborne yes
petusic
Harry yes
host yes Cole yes
Vocelli yes Paxton yes Walsh yes
Burrows yes
Herbert yes
clerk yes
McAleer yes
Vincent Yes collabro yes billio no
Gibbs yes
spear
yes
Sullivan
and chairman hunt
yes
19-1
okay
um
uh you do a are you gonna do a minori
report are you okay to put this on the
consent calendar let's go on the consent
calendar okay
all right all those in favor of the
consent Calendar please say aye
aye those opposed so moved unanimously
okay
okay so 167 uh yesterday when we were
discussing it
um it then
uh turned out that that it wasn't just
this one establishment that it was
having a problem but there were multiple
ones that has a problem and
um
uh I'm not sure Chagrin I I we didn't
you know belabor it they were going to
do a little more homework on it so this
morning uh for better for worse I have
to it takes me an hour and a half to
hour 15 minutes to drive in
um which I wouldn't have when we were in
the old days when I used to be zooming I
didn't have time to to contemplate my
navel but in this case I I called up the
commission I said
um and I had all the enforcement in the
room and I said so normally in a way
when we I know the history of how this
happened you know in terms of what we
were trying to do we were worried that
Nano somebody would try to open up a
nano in their in their living room and
then I said uh to them so normally if we
understand that there's this federal law
that requires that you've you know you
can't have in it in a residential
environment and that you can't it did no
residents should impede the way the
federal law has been impede your ability
to uh to enter the facility
um normally I would say is okay since
this is a statue that should really
apply not just a nano it should apply to
everybody
all you know beverage manufacturers but
I don't and that I'm not too excited
about passing I said so if it's already
federal statute why don't we just pass
this bill as is and repeal
the the the business requirement the
residential requirement specially since
it seems to have got the commissioner
the Commission in their enforcement
befuddled over the fact that they were
seen to be taking it a little farther
than what the actual legislative intent
was and their response was quickly is a
great idea let's just pass it
so
representative hunt seconded by
representative patusex booze
ought to pass question House Bill 160
is now open for discussion thank you
representative Herbert I'm just trying
to uh if I recall
um you you said that what this gentleman
actually wants is to be able to go on
the other side of the wall and tap in
other words serve in in his
establishment and that was his goal his
his problem was that he had he had
complied with the federal law yeah that
ensured that you could not get from the
residence right into the facility which
was a a barn attached to his house right
and so therefore he was in compliance
with the federal law but even more
importantly he was in compliance with
the legislative intent
of what the statute that was written
that we intended when we put it in okay
because we didn't we don't want liquor
enforcement to have to walk through any
residential any part of somebody's house
to get to the Nano you know the Nano
facility so given that he was in
compliance and that theoretically he was
going to be given permission to be in
compliant as soon as the commission you
know was able to get up and check out
his facility but what was scary was was
turns out that he wasn't the only one
that had this problem that there were
others that had the problem so even the
commission admitted that um the the law
that we had the current law now is
flawed and so the better part of valor
is just let's just get rid of it we
don't have to worry about the
legislative intent because that is
federal law now
um further further
um so these other instances that came to
the fore or right circled up those folks
all got the federal license they did
okay and and they got their license and
and they all had to pay the higher fee
to become uh beverage manufacturers when
they were actually their production
levels were very low so they really
comply to be Nanos
so this guy's gonna have to still pay
the uh well he's already paid the fee
but when his renewal which will come up
in June yeah he will be able to uh
reapply as a nano
it would renew his license as a nano
rather than him and the Liquor
Commission is
kosher they think that's a good idea all
right
thank you Mr chairman yes I believe uh
that when we discussed this it was
revealed that the federal requirement
had been satisfied because the uh
because the door had been padlocked
correct and the state was interpreting
the statute in such a way as to suggest
that even though it was padlocked
um that would that was not sufficient
correct so if we eliminate this we are
acknowledging what the feds are
acknowledging and that it that is that a
padlock is sufficient and it can
continue to be a nano and pay the Nano
fee rather than the higher fee
therefore I'm in support of it thank you
there you go all right any more
discussion on the motion about to pass
all right seeing none the clerk will
call the roll
Ammon yes
Osborne yes
for Tuesday yes
Terry yes
post yes
Cole yes
Bocelli yes Paxton yes Walsh yes
Burrows yes
Herbert yes
clerk yes
macklier yes
Vincent Yes
collabro yes
philio yes
Gibbs yes
spear
yes reluctantly
Sullivan yes
and Chapman hunt yes which one is it
good Tony zip all those in favor placing
on the consent Calendar please say aye
those opposed so moved unanimously
oh
it's a it really requires the work
279 yeah
okay
um 279 is being passed around
um so uh sometimes when we get an
amendment the amendment will only be
just uh that you would have to keep the
the bill itself in front of you and then
you have to look at the amendment and
kind of uh fold it in in this case they
just rewrote the whole thing so it
replaces it so replace it said so you
can see that this is It's always helpful
so you look at line one it says amend
the bill by replacing all after the
enacting Clause that's magic word saying
is this is the whole bill in uh all
together rather than just the amendment
so what the the uh critical change in
this bill
um was uh in lines uh it started 11 to
14 where uh in the original uh the bill
um but then we're saying if there is
document attendance by the licensees
Personnel at a commission sponsored by
educational program before the injury or
death either online or in person the
questions
that's not what I wanted I didn't think
so okay never mind this is wrong this
was the wrong one
yeah yeah no it was supposed to it was
supposed to be 10 days and then
automatic 30 days but I want to say this
is the way the commission uh the
commission I sent them the wrong file
sorry never mind we won't take this up
today
well it was it was sort of the chicken
the egg how do we how do we do this I my
intent was to be my intent was to be uh
that it's we maintain the 10 days which
is the current law but that uh if there
was if they had not gone through the
training it would have been 30 days
what's up
um
that was that's my fault I sent it I
sent the wrong file okay Mr chairman yes
I have a question yes
if you uh line four uh new paragraphs
serving intoxicated persons penalties in
case of serious bodily injury or death
so it's it's really only saying
that it's it's okay to serve somebody
overserve somebody as long as they don't
after the fact commit a crime isn't it
illegal to over serve somebody period
yeah what this section is about is what
are the penalties that the Liquor
Commission has to enforce so if you look
you know so you see that this is the the
and then you have the second offense
so the
this is a mess
yeah
shouldn't it read that it's illegal to
to over serve anyway that's somewhere
else
that's that's somewhere else in the
section all right well this what we're
well we're amending here is just the
penalty what the instructions to the the
judge who happens to be the Liquor
Commission that what their what the
penalties of overserving if someone
and if somebody gets hurt or dies so Mr
chairman if I understand this correctly
uh with respect to the 30 consecutive
days and the 7 500 in the situation with
it it uh it could very it could very
well then be 30 days in a fine of 7 500
resulting because
because they did not have the bartender
or whoever did not have the required
training correct so there's no
additional penalty for not having the
required training this is the maximum
penalty if there's no required if
there's no but under the current law
right now it does it just simply says 10
days right so this is 30 days now this
would be 30 days suspension it's 30 days
if there's no training oh correct
up to up to 30 days to 30 days that's
their discretion right okay thank you
okay Mr chairman yes a point of
clarification yes representative Terry
referred to required training is it am I
wrong but there is no required training
that is correct that's right that is
another issue that is the issue that the
issue that's been from this committee
multiple times was the Mandate training
right and and that always seemed to this
committee problematic right because
employees come and go right uh
unfortunately right now even more so
right yeah most ever before the
suggested training
okay I didn't want it to sound like we
had yeah no that was good clarification
okay moving right on let's go to now 531
relative to the taxation of tobacco and
you did
okay representative below second by
records and Vincent
and representative below is recognized
to speak to her motion
yeah I think this um Bill increases the
taxes on nicotine products
um and I did receive some phone calls
from constituents who own
um
smoking stores or like a Smoker's Haven
and um he explained that it really would
not uh really be any increase in revenue
for the state because uh many people
that are coming over the Border you know
border towns are buying the cigarettes
knowing that they're cheaper
um if they weren't cheaper than let's
say Massachusetts then they would buy
them in Massachusetts so we would lose
Revenue uh and not only that the
businesses that we want to
um assist in making money uh whether
they be you know smoke shops or not
um we really should be working uh in the
best interest for our business Community
as well so I think the increase in taxes
is
is not a good thing for the state
okay representative Burroughs
um I think there were
more people who were in agreement with
me who who
um were I say six to one I know but I
think two people am I correct may be
this is the first I've heard that I
remember
um argument yeah like when did we talk
about that on this before no what she
just said like yeah
during the hearing as well not not
executive session I mean not the um
subcommittee subcommittee we heard it um
the day we heard the bill from the
sponsor yeah
so they were the community business
owners came in and uh they were not for
this uh increase in you know taxes
because they said that they would lose
revenue and the state would lose Revenue
as well
I would I would just say that
um
I never allowed to see a business lose
money but in this case I think there's a
Public Health crisis around cigarettes
and frankly anything in my mind that
would would help people stop smoking
representative Gibbs I support uh what
representative Burroughs just said I
think this representative spear thank
you uh I accidentally voted the wrong
way last time so I'm one of those crazy
people but nonetheless yes we might lose
some Revenue
uh and and it's not going to be very
much but we're going to spend money on
health care as a result of these people
getting continuing with this smoking
thing not to say listen so I don't know
this what not if they live in
Massachusetts
then at the federal level my medicare is
going to get hit
you know I don't think that there's any
kind of a loss
I mean I don't think that I think we're
going to pay we may lose on this side
but we're going to gain on that side so
I the fact that a few tobacco outfits
are going to lose a little money May
save us all in the long run so just just
to make sure you're this is the liquor
committee and know you are not on the
liquor committee
that so that's six to one
you you might I wasn't able to vote then
anyway exactly
show off the hook on that one there you
go okay all right this is not being
recorded yes it is I know you know and
it drives me that's the camera there's
no red light on that camera okay
representative Benson thank you real
quick thank you Mr chairman real quick
uh what I don't like about this is it
took the control out of the state's
hands and put it in the board's hands
which that could be that's it I just I
get I'm getting this so thank you
perfect okay any more discussion on the
motion of innings speeding to legislate
Ammon yes
Terry yes
post yes
Cole yes
for jelly yes Paxton yes Walsh yes
Burrows no
Herbert
clerk yes
McAleer no
Vincent Yes
collabro yes
billio
no
Gibbs no
and chairman hunt
yes
all right one two three four five six
seven eight
10 11 12 13 14 15 2 5.
okay 15 to 5. so that will stay on the
regular calendar would there be a
Minority Report
yes and representative Burroughs you
will be doing The Minority Report
okay uh two more uh 612 relative to the
fees for New Hampshire wine
manufacturers
no we itl but you you it yelled it
I think was uh no on this yeah so just
to jog your memory okay is that we turns
out we do have a hundred dollar p p to
be a de minimis wine manufacturer
that uh we're not we don't see any
particular reason to change the sample
size from five ounce to six ounce
and then the third part which was to re
to repeal the wine tax the excise tax
for when a wine is not delivered through
the commission but is delivered directly
um uh it's self-delivered if we want to
call it that self-delivered or sold on
site that we would leave the tax at the
five percent
excise tax
so the motion represented below second
by representative Sullivan moves in
expedient to legislate and that's the
reason why
and that's the reason why you just said
it
any more discussion on the motion of it
out yes representative I had a chance to
talk to Mike Apollo after yesterday and
uh you want to pull the mic a little
closer I had a chance to talk to Mike
Apollo yesterday and um I represent two
wine uh independent wine
um companies in my district
um I think there is some Merit to their
complaints about the taxation issues I
think we might want to consider working
on that
part alone I don't I agree that it is
itl for the other elements of it but I
think that we should not just throw that
away
so you're saying that the five percent
is too high I do
I feel that they are being penalized and
the size of their operations are are
being thwarted these independent
Vineyards there are not a lot of them
but this is really
um unfair taxation compared to other
Industries as compared to the Beer the
30 cents a gallon beer tax but of course
in beer that that the tax you know is at
the uh wholesale rate and and so there's
a margin there right and and obviously
the wine this is uh an ability uh the
five percent was created
when we gave them the right to sell the
wine themselves because the law was
prior to that was they the only way you
could buy a bottle of wine in New
Hampshire
was through the Liquor Commission right
which The Liquor Commission then got its
much greater than five percent it got
its 25 margin so we were taking the
state was taking a hit to allow them to
trying to think about it
Mr chairman yes representative solo sir
I remember yesterday during the
discussion wasn't there a concern about
this being unconstitutional like having
different prices well I brought that up
if we were to try to do something
different in other words if we were to
say is that only the um only the large
wine guys
okay gals would be uh at the five
percent and that we would do something
Less in other words have a a lower
excess tax but the reality is that five
percent was already you know a steep
discount from what uh you know in terms
of selling it through the Liquor
Commission so so you're this is the in
lieu of the Liquor Commission you they
want to sell it straight so they don't
have to sell to the commission so the
theory is that that five percent
um is is a it is actually retail I think
so it in terms of what they end up
selling it for but they can obviously
sell it in a much higher price
factor in the five percent then when if
what they would sell it to the
it's still lower than room
right now they would have to pay the
rooms for meals if they opened the
bottle and gave them a sample and
charged them
for the sample but if they gave it to
them for free like they used to do in
the old days then there would be no
rooms and meal Stacks there's still
there's no rooms and meals tax if you
but if you're if you're uh I mean it in
terms of a lot of these when I mean
let's say that's what Nano was all about
was was that they really they were like
a wine bar I mean you'd come in and you
know you got all these different samples
and and
I know there's some when you're supposed
to do wine tasting California so you're
you're supposed to spit it out you're
not supposed to drink it you're just
supposed to Let's swirl it around a
little bit but the reality is people are
drinking it yes representative Gibbs
would it make sense to retain this bill
uh so as to be able to strip out
anything relating to samples and
um make sure that we were bringing
forward only something that would be a
tax or a fee honestly I don't care what
you call it
um that would be both constitutional and
fair as between wine and beer
manufacturing right well I was I'm
trying to emphasize that there is a
difference between beer and wine okay
and and that was that
um the concept that
the prophets of the of those wines right
now uh the one who's really making out
is the Liquor Commission
if you buy it through the Liquor
Commission but they came in and asked
for legislation to allow them to sell it
there on the farm or on in a farmer's
market
it's also okay so everyone says well
that's great uh but but how now but the
Liquor Commission is now losing out on
all the profit now we don't get anything
and the political compromise at that
time and no one seemed to have a problem
with it was the five percent
because it seemed like a very low number
in the scheme of things that at least
the state you know the that the
commission might not be making its money
on selling the wine but we're giving the
privilege to allow these uh wineries to
actually sell it themselves or go to
farmers markets and do all those
different things and all we're asking is
for our five percent cut so is the
difference between beer and wine the
fact that the Liquor Commission never
sold the beer anyway that is correct
that is correct thank you so so in our
for better for worse our forefathers
thought it was a great idea to keep loud
beer to continue through the the beard
distribution market so who knows what
the cut those Distributors are taking
beer distributors are taking but at the
end of the day when you were looking at
how much money the beer guys make before
they send it to the distributor to sell
it and take their mark up and and the
retailer puts his mark up as compared to
what the winery is now getting when they
sell it at their list price
um that's how we stumbled upon the five
percent
okay so if this motion of Ito fails then
I would then entertain a retain motion
but
I'm not sure what we're retaining at
that point
okay so the clerk is the is the motion
clear anybody else wanna
okay the clerk will call the role on
inexped into legislate on House Bill
612. correct Evan uh Ammon yes
Osborne yes batusic
Terry yes
post yes
Cole yes but jelly yes Paxton yes Walsh
yes sparrows yes
Herbert
clerk yes McAleer yes
Vincent Maybe
collabro
yes we'll come at this another day
billio yes
Gibbs yes
spear yes Sullivan
so motion is Ito yeah below oh yeah
so could you get the chair of science
and technology did he gets it did he get
you did he think that that was funny
I have said maybe before in science
technology putting money just to then
turn up the heat a little bit um keep
okay
uh that's unanimous all those in favor
placing it on the consent Calendar
please say aye aye those opposed so
and the majority report is below
I'll rate the blurb that's right okay
um at this point uh I don't think we're
gonna take up 130 because we're we're
still working on this drug affordability
issue so
I think we can skip that one for today
and therefore I rule that we are out of
so I don't think anybody Minds it I just
bought them by their last name I mean
that's how it usually is right
yeah
represent
representative Fila
Leo they're really okay
just know there is no o on the end
the more uh vowels you put at the end
you call me below below nobody calls
thank you I think it is okay hold on a
few minutes
[Laughter]
I have so many fans at home and then I